- We're told that a standard
deck of 52 playing cards
includes four aces, four
kings, and 44 other cards.
Suppose that Luis
randomly draws four cards
without replacement.
What is the probability
that Luis gets two aces
and two kings, in any order?
So like always,
pause this video and see if
you can work through this.
All right.
Now, to figure out this probability,
we can think about this,
it's going to be the number of,
let's call them draws
with exactly two aces and two kings,
two aces and two kings.
And that's going to be
over the total number of
possible draws of four cards.
So number
of possible draws
of four cards.
Now, for many of y'all,
this bottom, the denominator here,
might be a little bit
easier to think about.
We know that there's 52 total cards,
of which we are choosing four.
So we could say 52 choose four,
and that will tell us the total number
of possible draws of four cards.
How many combinations
of four cards can we get
when we're picking from 52?
But the top here might be a
little bit more of a stumper.
We can think we have
exactly two spots for aces,
so we're choosing two aces
out of how many possible aces?
Well, there's four total aces.
So if we say four choose two,
this is the total number of ways,
when you don't care about order,
that you can have two out
of your four aces picked.
And then separately,
we can use similar logic to say,
all right, there's also
four choose two ways
of picking two kings out
of four possible kings.
And now the total number of draws
with two aces and two kings,
this is going to be the
product of these two.
And if you're wondering why
you can just multiply it,
think about it.
For every scenario that
you have these two aces,
you have four choose two scenarios
of which kings you're dealing with.
So you would take the product of them.
And we've already done many examples
of computing combinatorics like this,
so I will leave you there.
If you're so motivated,
I encourage you to be,
you can actually calculate this value.